The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: So
today, we're going
to talk about labor
and development.
There are several
pieces to this,
just to sort of get into it.
One, number one, back to
risk sharing, full benchmark,
but this time with endogenous
labor supply and wage risk.
And I'll mention sort of some
tests using that framework.
I dumped a lot of
the excess slides,
because I don't want that to be
the sole focus of the lecture
today, although it's kind of
the obvious starting point.
With those lotteries,
basically, you
end up dealing with
a non-convexity.
And then that has a lot to do
with estimating elasticities
of labor supply from
micro data versus what
you see in aggregate data.
And we've learned
a lot about that.
So there is sort of the
complete market's version.
And then, a la lecture last
time, the incomplete market's
version, where the aggregate
elasticity is higher, sometimes
a lot higher, than it is in
the micro data for reasons
of the aggregation.
And since we've talked
about zoom in, zoom out,
you know, micro, macro, that
seems like a relevant thing.
And then we, in fact, end
the lecture with Seema's,
Jayachandran, paper
on labor supply.
And I think it was
India, with rainfall
and agricultural shock.
So sharing wage risk,
I just said this.
We have non-labor income, which
is like the y moving around
we've had before.
But we also have
income from wages,
but hours are endogenous.
Labor is not supplied
inelastically.
And we're going to allow for
heterogeneity among individuals
in a household and
heterogeneity across households.
So let me just lead
off with an example,
because I think it makes
the points pretty well.
And then we'll generalize.
So you have two people,
or two households.
One is risk neutral.
The other risk averse.
Why is this an obvious example?
Because the risk neutral guy
should absorb all the risk
and would in every setup
that we've seen so far
and take it away
from the risk averse
guy, who's got a strictly
concave utility function.
However, this guy cares about
leisure and consumption, not
just consumption.
So typical Cobb-Douglas
specification
with some curvature, making
him strictly concave guy.
If you don't consume leisure
in your work, that's supplied.
You get this wage, W2.
When we generalize, we're
going to allow different wage
processes for different people,
not modeling necessarily
why they have different talent.
But for now, there's only
one guy supplying labor.
Again, y is this
non-labor income.
T is the time endowment.
Consumption good
is the numeraire.
Wages are real.
And there is a budget constraint
for this two-person programming
problem, which is like a small
open economy in the sense
that it's partial
equilibrium, and they
face these outside wages.
In fact, these wages
may be moving around.
It could be a village with two
people, something like that.
Wages are determined in the
district or national level.
This is the standard
budget constraint though.
Call this thing full income,
if you remember Becker price
theory.
So basically, it's as if
you supplied all the time
you have, cap T, hours
and days times the wage.
You have this non-labor income.
The community as
a whole has this.
And then, you have
consumption and Mr. 2 at least
buys back leisure.
You know, well, it's
obvious, you could just
take time minus leisure.
That would be labor supply and
put it on the right hand side.
But it's kind of useful to
talk about leisure as a good,
because that's what enters
the utility function.
And we have some standard sort
of consumption sharing rules,
division rules.
Who's going to bear the risk?
Well, it's going to turn out
that as we've done so far,
this non-labor income risk
is going to be shared--
taken away entirely
by household 1.
But things are much
more complicated
when it comes to the wage.
The wage moves around,
and it changes income.
But the wage also
represents a rate
of substitution between
consumption and leisure
for the group as a whole,
even though person 2
has to supply it.
You know, the wage
goes way up, there's
kind of a change to
opportunity set for the group.
And you can imagine
things should
move in order to be efficient
to take that into account.
So we solved the
problem in two steps.
And that's also going to make
it familiar in the sense of it
integrates with what we've
been talking about so far.
First, ex post
inefficiency, suppose--
ex post efficiency-- this
is like the second welfare
theorem.
But I'll tell you what I mean.
Any Pareto optimal
allocation can
be supported among households
with a suitable lump sum
taxes and subsidies.
Remember that theorem?
OK, so what does it mean for us?
You can kind of decentralize
the problem of the two people,
as if one or later both can
supply labor on their own.
But this lump sum
tax or transfer
is like an internal
redistribution
within the household.
So for any target Pareto
optimal allocation,
you can find a transfer and
then have each act in isolation,
maximizing utility.
And then step 2 is to take
sort of those indirect utility
functions, take a
step back in time
and maximize the ex
ante expected utility.
And that's going to look like a
standard risk sharing problem.
And in this case, for
this baby example,
only member 2 is
supplying labor.
Remember it was Cobb-Douglas,
and the power was basically 2.
So basically here it's easier.
You take 1/2 of
your full income.
And that's your consumption.
So those are those easy kind of
consumption expenditure rules.
This is actually the same.
You put the wage over here.
The value of leisure is again
1/2 of your full income.
So those are with
that functional
form standard leisure
consumption for household 2,
plug it back into the
underlying utility function,
raise it to a power, and you
may remember working this out
at some point in
some other course.
You get a standard
indirect utility function
with all this stuff going on
in terms of these coefficients.
Well, it's kind of obvious
that it had to end up this way.
Note that the wage is in
here a couple of times,
partly because the
full income and partly
because this guy's optimizing--
as the wage changed,
say, the allocation,
the maximizing
allocation would change.
You've got an
indifference curve,
and you're going to change
the slope of the budget line.
So now we take that
step back and consider
the overall maximum.
But instead of having utility of
consumption directly of the two
members, we can use
the indirect functions.
I mean, if you believed me,
then the indirect function
is without any restrictions.
It's a natural object that
represents efficient ex post
optimization.
Here's that row.
Did I-- I should
have emphasized it.
Row is the amount that
say 2 is getting from 1.
Those are the
internal transfers.
And household 2 optimizes
for a given row.
So the ex ante allocation is
set the marginal utilities
basically equal to each
other, or equal to a constant.
This constant would be the
ratio of Pareto weights.
I'm not saying that two members
have to be treated equally
within the household.
It could be very asymmetric.
We usually have lambda 1 over
lambda 2, or mu 1 over mu 2,
or some ratio of those ex
ante given Pareto weights.
That's all embedded up
here in the constant.
Of course, convenient part
is the indirect utility
of household 1 is just linear,
because that person had
a utility that depended
only on consumption.
And it was linear
in consumption.
So we can now,
with this constant,
if we carry it around
and multiply, you know,
keep track that parameters
get added or multiplied
to it, that we can get a
closed form solution from this
for the transfer rule.
And we already know what
consumption and leisure
are for person 2 as a
function of the transfer.
So we solve that.
And I don't know,
it's just algebra.
What do you want
to see down here?
Well, person 1's consumption
is moving around one to one
with non-labor income.
So as anticipated, member 1
is absorbing all of that risk
and member 2 is
absorbing none of it.
But the wage is affecting
consumption and more obviously
labor supply of person 2.
And that wage is actually
affecting person 2 as well.
Here it is down here in--
person 1, sorry, in terms
of person 1's consumption.
And it's doing it in a
particular way basically.
So this paper is called
sharing wage risk.
And both these members
will share the wage risk,
even though only person 2
can work more or less hours
at that wage.
So in some sense,
leisure pooling
is a bit different from
consumption pooling in the way
that they're going
to want to adjust
their hours is going to depend
on the outside opportunities.
So that's the summary.
And then we'll
generalize this case.
It's not general, because
person 1 was risk neutral.
Here's the general case.
There are S states of the world.
There's a risk sharing group
of households, as in a village
or township or something.
And every household H
has individual members.
It could be more than one.
It's likely to be two or three.
This is meant to be realistic.
And we actually go to the data
with these specifications.
And we have hours and
labor force participation
for every member
of the household.
So we normally only have
consumption for the household.
So we kind of throw
up our hands a bit,
but here, we have labor at
the level of individuals.
And we definitely
want to keep track.
The consumption
of household H is
a sum of consumption
of individual members.
That's true in theory,
even if we don't measure it
individually in practice.
Aggregate consumption
in the village
is a sum of consumption
across the households.
Nothing surprising there.
Utilities of everyone
stays strictly increasing
and concave.
And household H faces a vector
of wage and non-labor income
variation.
You know the S is a subscript
on the wages of person
1, the wages of person
2, for how many people
there are in this household.
And again, here
although it really
doesn't matter because we're
going to added up anyway,
you could say different
people in the household
have different occupations.
Some are helping on the farm.
Other people run the
business exclusively.
You could talk about
the non-wage income.
If there's perfect markets,
which we're going to assume,
then the profits
of the firm are as
if they had supply their
own labor to the market
and hire other labor to run the
business, which is problematic.
But, you know, then you get
the usual sort of separation.
And so these are really
like profit numbers.
But this is the aggregate
of overall individuals
in the household.
This is what we've been
calling household profits.
And finally, the
resources available
are household profits plus
gifts and other things.
These taus are not
yet determined.
They're given for this household
H in state S. In a minute
they're going to get
determined endogenously
from the rest of the village.
So, again, we're
going to kind of solve
individual problems, household
problems, village problems,
and sort of build upwards.
So what does the household do?
It maximizes these
new weighted sums
of utilities of its individual
members, summing over states.
And actually, we
could sum over dates.
But you already know
that doesn't matter.
There's nothing you know
particularly inter-temporal
about this--
well, these sub-problems
apply even when
the household as a whole
can borrow and lend
with the outside, et cetera.
And just simplify by
getting rid of that for now.
Common probability over states
S. Utilities are allowed
to depend on individual i.
We're going to try to retain as
much heterogeneity as possible,
although it's sometimes
problematic how much we
can allow in the data.
And here's the sort of
collective resource constraint
for the household H.
It's the same as before.
We're just summing over
all the individual members.
This is the sum consumption,
sum of the valuation of leisure,
equal to full income,
including any taxes
or subsidies the
household is getting
from the rest of the village.
These Pareto weights mu
are kind of taken as given.
That's not to say there aren't
forces that determine them--
you know, the marriage
market, one person
has a lot more income than the
other, all this bargaining.
But any bargaining that takes
place here is entirely ex ante.
And it is assumed to be fixed
and unalterable subsequently
as states of the
world are realized.
You know, we haven't talked
about it in this class.
I think you've probably
seen it in other classes,
this whole literature
on the unitary household
and, you know, ex
post bargaining,
when opportunities of the
spouse increase and so on.
They may take more goods.
They may better dictate
what household is consuming.
That's all suppressed here.
It's buried in these
fixed Pareto weights.
The idea is to see how far we
can get even assuming that.
OK, well, then we have
the Marshallian demand.
I only say that with
emphasis because we're
going to go Hicks and
Frisch in a minute.
But this is the regular
demand for leisure
that solves the individual's
optimization problem.
This is an individual
i in household H.
This, apart from the
more cumbersome notation,
is exactly what we
went through before.
This is some transfer that
individual i is getting
in state S from the rest--
giving or getting from
the rest of the members
of the household.
This is the
valuation of the time
endowment for individual i.
And in the left-hand side
is the sum of expenditures
on consumption and leisure.
And that after maximization
gives you the indirect utility
function, which clearly
depends on the wage
and on this transfer.
So for the household to
have an objective function,
we can call it sort of
the Pareto mu weighted sum
of the value functions
of the individuals.
Again, we went through
this in the baby example
at the beginning.
And then the problem
of the village--
note that now we summed over H--
is to maximize this household
by household expected utility,
and now making it expected
because it's conditioned
on state S. And here's the
constraint that these transfers
stay within the
village have to add up
to zero if the village is
the risk sharing group you
want to be considering.
One first order
condition, you know,
basically says that the marginal
utility of the household
respective transfers in state
S is just pre-multiplied
by the probability and
then this lambda HS--
so this lambda HS is
like the shadow price
on the budget constrain
of the household at state
S. It reflects
how tight or loose
the optimization
problem is, just
like in standard price theory.
It's just the
Lagrange multiplier
on the budget constraint.
It's also going to
equal something else.
But so far I haven't talked
about it in the notation.
It's going to equal
something else,
because these sum of
the transfers are zero.
So there's like a collective
resource constraint that isn't
written out here explicitly.
And that thing is going to
pick up a Lagrange multiplier.
And that Lagrange
multiplier is going
to be common over
all the households,
just like it was for
the consumption problem.
OK, so here's an example,
Cobb-Douglas coefficients
are depending on i and
H raised to a power.
This obvious generalization
of the example.
We have a little corner
to worry about here.
You know, the way to see
this is putting w over here,
this is the
expenditures on leisure.
And expenditures on leisure
ought to be equal to--
well, these add up
to 1, basically--
I almost think that's a typo.
Should be 1 minus alpha--
the expenditure
share on leisure.
But what happens if this
amount, given this full income,
this leisure that individual
i is supposed to be consuming,
exceeds his time endowment?
Then you've hit
a binding corner.
So hence the min, which is
this cannot exceed this.
When it's less, it's no problem.
You just when hours are
less, you do those hours.
When hours are more,
you do the max.
Now, let me just say this is
very natural in this problem
when the time
endowment is fixed.
But you could also imagine
other indivisibilities.
You could imagine that
you could only supply
discrete amount of hours.
Or something like in
the US, typically you
have 8-hour days and 40-hour
weeks, and that's it.
And you can't vary your hours.
So you can load other
restrictions in here.
And in the data, there
is enormous variability
in non-participation.
Month by month,
households will sit out
for substantial periods
of times and then re-enter
the labor force.
So something is
making that happen.
And actually, it's
the other corner.
It's more like zeros, not
working up to the max.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So it only
gets a corner solution
if that household's Pareto bases
is too large for that agent?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: That's
one of the factors.
No, too small.
So-- oh, too large,
sorry, leisure.
And I just made a
mistake, absolutely, yeah.
So when the Pareto weight is
high and leisure is valued,
then they want to
do maximum leisure.
They set leisure equal to the
time endowment and work hours
are zero.
So that's one thing, but
it depends on the wage.
And it's actually
going to depend
on how binding the household's
resource constraint is.
So there's two other factors.
But you're right about
the Pareto weight.
So we can solve out for the
value functions in these work
and no work branches.
I'm not sure that is
very enlightening.
There is going to be a
critical wage, as I was just
anticipating, where that
constraint is binding
or not if the wages are higher
than this critical number,
the individual would be working.
And if it's lower than
that critical number,
they're not going to be working.
So there is a threshold.
And it turns out it's
smooth as the wage-- there's
no jumps in this
problem, at least.
You can see it in
the value functions.
You can see it in the
way the wage moves.
But again, I don't
think it's worth getting
bogged down in the algebra
to make that point.
In other words, hours
will kindly smoothly
stay at zero until the wage
goes above this threshold.
And then hours will start
to pick up in a regular way.
So here's what I just
mentioned to Yeng,
which is that households are
less likely to participate when
the wage is low, when the
household is doing well,
and when the Pareto
weight is large.
Or conversely, you'll see
greater participation,
and condition on
participation, greater hours
when the wage is high, when
the household is doing badly,
meaning that the shadow price on
the budget constraint is high,
and when this person's
Pareto weight is small.
You know, make the slaves work.
This looks awful.
It supposed to be a
good thing that we
are able to analytically solve.
So let me highlight something.
There's two equations
on the slide.
There's a reservation wage
and an hour's equation.
OK?
Actually look down here first.
The reservation wage for
individual i in the household h
has a constant
term and something
that depends on the shadow
price of the budget.
Now, when we did the
consumption risk sharing thing,
we talked about the shadow
price of consumption.
I'm kind of like tongue tied.
I don't quite know
what to call it.
It's more than
consumption, because we
have leisure in this problem.
But we did have a
budget constraint.
So it's the shadow price
on the budget constraint.
And there's no H on this guy,
because this thing represents
that all the individuals and all
the households in the village
are pooling all this risk.
So there's like a common
community level resource
constraint.
That's the content
of the theory.
And here's hours actually
worked when working.
And again, it has
a constant term.
It has this same shadow
price object, DS,
in it, and also on the wage.
Now, the wage just
reflects the fact that,
as we said before,
the higher the wage,
the more you're likely
to make someone work.
And so now we can maybe get
the courage to go back up
and look at what all
these objects are.
Look at all the
beautiful restrictions
that theory is placing on
these regression coefficients.
First of all, why
all the i's and h's?
Well, we allowed a
lot of heterogeneity
in those Cobb-Douglas
coefficients and the curvatures
for each of the households.
Let's spot some familiar--
this is all preference stuff.
This is cool for me.
This is the log of the
probability weighted shadow
price in the whole village.
And what's this?
This is the risk aversion.
So you remember that stuff
about risk tolerance?
So, you know, the greater gamma,
the less risk tolerant they
are--
sorry, going the wrong way.
This gamma is the curvature
in the utility function.
So-- oh, there's a
negative sign there, right.
So basically what it's
saying is the more risk
averse that an
individual is, the less
you should see that its
hours are moving around
with this aggregate state.
So that's the leisure version
of the consumption equations
we had before.
I mean here's Pareto weights
in here, for example,
in the critical wage threshold.
This is the Pareto
weight of the household.
weight of the individual.
And the higher this thing
is, the higher that wage
is going to be, because
that's basically
the way you take your leisure.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So before
we were talking
about it's great to see all
these restrictions because
of being familiar with the
data and doing regression.
But we will never have data
on a Pareto weight, right?
That's not a real thing?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: That's true.
But--
AUDIENCE: If that's correlated
with other stuff that's
going to start moving
around the other betas
that we're estimating on
the stuff we can see, right?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah, but
basically-- that's right.
And that's what
this is basically.
So you start looking at what
the regression coefficients are.
For example, here's this
one thing, the risk aversion
of individual i and household
h, and there's an F on there.
So where was the F thing?
The F thing was what I was
highlighting right here.
So now this is a fixed effect.
We don't see it.
But you can put a time
bearing fixed effect
for the whole village.
And then estimate this
regression coefficient.
And the theory is telling you
that's 1 over the coefficient
of relative risk aversion.
And so now you can work
backwards, you know--
AUDIENCE: Wouldn't
that be correlated
with the Pareto weight on me?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Mm, hmm.
No.
No, we didn't see that in the--
AUDIENCE: Oh, no,
sorry, what I meant
is if I don't have
the Pareto weight--
so that'll be like
fixed effect, right?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: The Pareto
weights is like a fix--
this is a time
bearing fixed effect.
And the Pareto weights
are going to show up--
where are they?
Over here.
Here's one.
AUDIENCE: Can you have some--
ROBERT TOWNSEND: This is the
households' Pareto weight.
This is the individual's
Pareto weight.
Granted there's a little bit
of these alphas to worry about.
So we'll have to grab them.
But part of this
fixed effect, this
is not varying with time
or states or anything else.
AUDIENCE: So you can have
like an individual effect is
what you're saying.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah.
So that's sort
of-- the algebra is
if you had all these regression
coefficients and so on,
then you basically can identify
almost all these parameters.
The thing that you
can actually get
is the absolute value
of the risk tolerance.
And we actually
saw that earlier.
It's the ratio of the risk
tolerance of household i
relative to other members
that you're actually
able to identify.
You can see who's more risk
averse than others, but not--
OK, and actually the paper
itself goes through--
it's long.
I'm afraid it's quite tedious--
goes through, you know,
this parametric example.
It actually goes through
non-parametric stuff.
Pierre-Andre has figured
out with his co-authors
how to identify tons of stuff,
just based on labor supply,
even though there's all
this underlying consumption
stuff going on.
You use data from Britain.
OK.
So yep?
AUDIENCE: So you starting
out with the multiplication
that consumption will
have to equal to waste.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: But your
paper in 1994--
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So how do you
reconcile with this?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Well, I mean,
the first answer was, you know,
I assumed the problem away.
Actually, not quite.
If you look, you'll see that
I had put measures of hours
in the consumption equations.
I was aware of this even then.
But it certainly would be
easy to make a mistake.
And people are often critical,
like puzzled, how can you
say income shouldn't matter?
And here, we are
distinguishing the income
that's coming from labor
supply versus the income that's
non-labor.
And it matters.
The theory places
restrictions on how.
So in some sense, consumption
does move with income.
If the wage is moving income,
then it's moving consumption.
And it's moving
consumption of everyone.
AUDIENCE: Not quite generally.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: No, it's just
from the first order conditions
of the optimum problem,
the baby example
that I gave at the
very beginning.
AUDIENCE: So why are we
testing a social planning
problem instead of
competitive equilibrium.
Is that because Thailand
economy is centrally--
ROBERT TOWNSEND: There
is no social planning.
AUDIENCE: Isn't just to see how
close we get to the benchmark?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah.
First of all, it's not
a particular benchmark,
because those fixed effects--
we want to see where we are
in the whole frontier, right?
AUDIENCE: I guess there's
a menu of benchmarks.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yes.
So the idea is somehow like
sort of a closed thing,
that you wouldn't leave,
quote, "surplus on the table."
That there must be
markets or institutions
or other arrangements that lead
them toward efficient outcomes.
But, yeah, it's not like--
it's interesting that you're
against the social planner.
It's-- and I often slip, and
you caught me the other day,
saying, you know, social
planner this and that when I did
the capital asset model.
That's just a metaphor for--
it's as if the
community as a whole
is allocating resources so
as to not lose any surplus.
Now, you know, exactly
what the institution--
so I should tell you
about what we find.
First of all, in these
villages, there's
something called labor
exchange arrangements.
And it's partly
with the rice thing.
You know, the low land
gets flooded early.
They all go down and help
that guy farm his land.
And then as the water rises,
they flood the other plots.
But they don't charge
each other for the labor.
It looks like free
labor exchange.
And it doesn't necessarily
balance out either.
Now, I'm not saying in any given
economy you'd be lucky enough
to observe something like that.
But in these villages
you actually do
have a real institutional
counterpart that might explain
how they managed to do so well.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So I'm not sure it
would matter for this model.
But the story you
told is that there's
several risk
sharing arrangements
for a different domain.
That one was labor
opportunities.
Maybe there's a separate
one for consumption.
Would it matter-- from
what perspective would it
matter if there were
one unified arrangement?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: No,
it wouldn't matter.
But, you know, it's nice
to be able to say something
about what the mechanism is.
You know, for some people
just looking at outcomes
isn't totally convincing.
I must say when
I started this, I
thought it was a virtue to
say we don't care how it's
done, I'm not going to look
separately as savings accounts,
selling bullocks, borrowing,
running down your grain stores,
let's just look at the total.
But still people want to know
how it could possibly happen.
So what's going
on in these data?
Well, I spare you
all the details.
But we put non-labor income
on the right-hand side
of the participation equations
and the labor supply equations.
And the coefficient on it is
small and quite negligible.
I mean, it's not zero.
So we reject.
But, you know, if
you come at this--
and we'll see this
in Seema's paper--
if you come at this from the
traditional point of view
in development, it would be
like labor supply is your safety
net.
If you're getting your income
is really low from crops,
then migrate out,
work for wages.
And this says,
well, not so fast.
It might be done at
a community level.
And the test of it would
be whether how well you're
doing on your own land has any
influence on your participation
and your labor supply.
If they're pooling
risk like this,
it shouldn't once you control
for, say, village level
fixed effects.
And, in fact, you reject.
But the coefficients are tiny.
They really are sharing a lot
of this risk, not all of it,
but a lot of it.
OK, one last thing just to
tie some of this literature
to-- oh, god.
So this thing, this is
like a famous parameter,
because it's called
the Frisch elasticity.
And that brings to the next
part of this lecture, which
is this tension between the
small estimates, micro level
estimates, of labor elasticities
compared to what we seem
to need in a model to
get aggregate hours
and participation and
move around so much.
Now, this literature spans
micro and macro and development.
From the macro side,
Chetty reviewed all of it.
But, you know,
Sargent, for example,
but way back to Rogerson
and Hansen talk about a way
I'm going to show you
an indivisibility that
makes the overall aggregate
elasticities a lot
higher than you would get if
you looked at those individuals
in the data.
So again, just to
anticipate, this
is a bit like zooming
out and zooming in.
You zoom in to the individuals.
If you have labor
supply and so on,
you can estimate their
micro level elasticities.
And there's just
tons of literature,
which I suppressed
from the slides,
because it will overwhelm
you of the interest
in estimating
those elasticities.
But you could say all
these individuals reside
in a village or district.
Let's look at what happens
when there's a rainfall shock.
Let's look at aggregate--
how much the wage is moving
as a function of the rainfall
shock and try to
estimate from there
how inelastic labor supply is.
And it's natural that
aggregate up over individuals
to get an aggregate
labor supply if you're
talking about how district
wages move around with rainfall.
Well, that's Seema's
paper at the end.
She's seemingly not aware,
and she didn't make a mistake.
But it would be quite easy
to make a mistake if you were
quantitatively trying to
reconcile the data that you
use in the aggregate with
the micro level elasticities.
And so that's, as
it turns out, been
the focus of this of
this macro literature, so
many elasticities.
And partly because the
different literatures
developed different jargon.
There is the
Hisksian elasticities
and the Frisch elasticities.
A Hisksian elasticity is
basically compensated.
So when you have
a wage change, you
don't just look at total hours.
You push people back to the
original indifference curve
and slide along it.
That's Hicks.
Frisch has to do with
variation that you
would see if you held the
marginal utility of wealth
constant.
Why does that come up for us?
Oh, risk sharing.
The marginal utility
of wealth is basically
at each date and state constant
over all the individuals.
It's a very natural object and
related to the risk sharing
literature.
And then macro, they call--
just to add Frisch elasticity.
But it's of aggregate hours.
And every one of these things
has extensive and intensive.
And that's because there's a
big variation in participation,
not just hours in any data
that people have looked at.
I'm not sure Chetty did this.
I'm not so sure
how helpful it is.
But the idea is the Hicks
effect is like shifting a wage.
And you're going to shift it--
if you're going to
distinguish age,
you shift it over the
entire age profile.
That's the way he
thinks about it.
Whereas he thinks about
the Frisch elasticity
as just one little instant.
I have trouble relating,
but anyway this is--
and then there's this table.
These are micro estimates of
the intensive means conditioned
on working, how much your hours
are varying with your wage.
These are, quote unquote,
"relatively low" numbers,
0.3, 0.5.
The extensive margin is in the
micro data also not big, 0.1,
0.2.
What this literature is
about is aggregate hours.
Aggregate hours have
higher elasticities
than any of those numbers.
And in particular this
thing, this macro level,
Frisch elasticity is huge.
So in order to generate this
number that we see in the data,
and keep the micro
parameters that you're
going to fit in, to be
consistent with that you have
to generate a huge elasticity
on the extensive margin somehow.
So this is about trying to
reconcile micro with macro.
AUDIENCE: Is that
bottom line, they're
not estimates from the data?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Which one?
AUDIENCE: The bottom line.
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
Yeah, they're not.
Although this is like that.
So let's respect the
data on that dimension.
And somehow create a very
big number here somehow--
and I'll tell you
how in a minute--
in order to get what we
see in the data over here.
Now, in the original slides--
I'll give them to you--
there's like six
slides that now come
you know with all these other
who did this and which author
and so on.
And I just felt that was going
to be bewildering and certainly
time consuming.
So I'm skipping it.
But here's what I
already went through.
And I guess I said this too.
So the punch line
is going to be if we
have a non-convexity
in participation,
like you either have to work
full-time or not at all,
is an extreme.
And then we go through the
mechanics of how people
would behave in that economy.
We can generate a sort of
pseudo representative consumer.
So that it looks as
if the aggregate are
generated as a solution to
that representative household.
And the trick is that
representative household
is going to end up with
a Frisch elasticity
in the pseudo function, which
will allow huge variability
in aggregate hours.
It responds to wages.
Yep.
AUDIENCE: This doesn't match
the extensive margin micro data.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Because
it doesn't have to.
AUDIENCE: Why?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Because you
can populate the underlying
individuals with actual observed
micro estimates and then say
there is this inelasticity.
I'll show you.
OK, so we have labor,
capital, and output.
Let's just do a single period.
Imagine for a minute it's
not stochastic either.
We have an aggregate
production function,
as a function of aggregate
capital and aggregate hours
Why are we doing it?
This is basically
just going to allow
us to close the model
instead of having
it open partial equilibrium.
So we're going to get the
wage and interest rate off
of this thing.
It's convenient.
There are a continuum of
individuals indexed by i.
Each individual has one unit
of time, one unit of capital.
Time is indivisible.
And you got to choose, you're
either going to do leisure
or you're going to do work.
So that's an extreme version
of the indivisibility.
They care about
consumption and leisure,
or the disutility of work.
But this work level is
either 0 or 1 by assumption.
So let's just normalize
and say v of 0 is 0.
But v of 1 is whatever it is.
Let's call it m.
It's just a real number,
because you're never
going to see at the
individual level
any other levels of hours.
So remember m is the
disutility of working 1--
putting all your time into work.
What's the consumption
set in this economy?
Consumption is non-negative.
You can't supply more
capital than what you own.
But you have this non-convexity
in the labor decision.
It's 0, 1.
This is not an interval 0 to 1.
It's either 0 or 1.
It's the set consisting
of just the two objects.
So it's a non-convex
consumption set.
Linear combinations of
0 and 1 are not allowed.
OK, so what would be a
competitive equilibrium?
Households max, firms
max, markets clear.
Here's the household
max problem.
For any individual i, solve
for the consumption decision
about participation and the
capital respecting the budget
constraint.
Namely, you can work or not--
so this is either 0 or something
positive-- at a given wage.
And then you get the rental
rate on your capital stock.
And that's that.
Firms maximize profits,
paying factors of production.
Clearly for a given
f, this is going
to generate marginal
products of capital and labor
in the whole economy.
And if we just solve
the problem this way,
we could get an equilibrium.
But it might not be optimal.
We can make people better
off by sort of randomizing
who gets to work.
How are we going to do that?
We're going to basically create
this probability object phi.
So here would be the
expected utility given a phi.
The realization with
probability phi,
you're going to be the
worker in this economy.
With probability 1 minus phi,
you're just not going to work.
And at the moment, you can
get different consumption
for the two different branches.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: I sort
of understand this
is getting at which the
market might be flexible.
There's not much part-time.
There's not much
intensive margin.
So people turn to things like
household and they specialize.
But how do you interpret
the lottery as--
like we imposed
lumpiness of working.
And then we use the
lottery to break it.
Why not have some other way
of having other types of labor
worked?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Um--
well, I'm about to show you
on the next slide the decision
problem for an insurance
company.
And the insurance
companies like pooling over
all the individuals.
And it's going to maximize, and
there's going to be free entry.
And that's going to drive
the prices of certain things
to be equal to their
actuarial values.
So it's as if people were
buying and selling insurance.
And they get to choose--
they're not forced
as if by a planner
to work or not work depending
on how the roulette wheel turns.
They actually get to
choose voluntarily
whether to decide to work
full time, decide to work zero
or be on call.
They'd be on call, they're
going to get a wage that's
proportional to the
probability, because that's
the pooling aspect of it.
AUDIENCE: Like [INAUDIBLE]
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah, so far.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I don't know that the
lottery is so great, because it
could be we have like some of us
turn up for the job interviews,
and the people doing the
job interviews like just--
you know, they're picking
based on some stuff.
Maybe it's just as
good as random, right?
Like so--
AUDIENCE: That's crazy.
AUDIENCE: No, it's not.
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
Disconcerting maybe.
AUDIENCE: Suppose there are like
100 unskilled manual laborers
turned up for a job that
requires 30 laborers.
I cannot observe past
project of these laborers.
Like I can maybe
observe cleanliness
and they're ability to speak.
Like that's about it.
So what am I supposed to do.
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
So that would be
an institutional arrangement,
where the markets seem
not to clear, because not
everyone gets the allocation,
not everyone supplies labor.
You know, they're lined
up on the street corner,
and the truck comes by, and
there are only so many jobs.
AUDIENCE: But what if
we were indifferent,
then it would still be--
ROBERT TOWNSEND: But there
are other ways to do it.
I mean you could have sunspot.
You can even index off
of observable things
like rainfall.
And then it would look
like a state contingent
contract, where the labor supply
is a function of the rainfall.
But that doesn't mean
everyone's supplying labor.
They have some arrangement.
If it's sunny, I'm working.
If it's raining, you're working.
And it would be
very hard to say,
unless you were
very clear headed,
whether it's this sort
of extraneous risk
or some intrinsic risk,
some underlying state
that they were trying
to insure against.
This last interpretation
is Arrow's interpretation
of the lottery.
And he's entitled.
OK, so we're going to have these
prices, rental rates and wage
rates, normalizing
the consumption good.
OK, here's the
insurance company thing.
Basically, if you're working,
you pay a premium ex post.
And if you're not working,
you get this indemnity.
Well, I mean intuitively
if you're working,
you have more income, you
kind contribute some back
to the pool.
But if an insurance company
we're offering this,
they would potentially
make profits
depending on the fraction
of the people from whom they
get the premium and
the residual fraction
to whom they pay the indemnity.
If you have free
entry into insurance,
then this is going to drive
this equation to zero.
OK?
So that's going to tie the
premia and the indemnity
to the probability or
fraction of people working.
So now, we're going
to decentralize it.
We're going to say look it's
as if the household were
maximizing expected utility, but
as I said, voluntarily deciding
whether to work for sure or
not work at all or something
in between.
And then they're going to
have this resource constraint.
But I've now substituted in--
the x's entered
into consumption.
But the x's we're constrained
by that zero profit condition.
So we've substituted in
the zero profit condition
back into the household
budget constraint
and gotten this equation.
Capital is equal to 1.
So this thing's just going
to go to 1 no matter what.
You're going to get a wage.
But you're basically
going to be paid
the expected value of
your pre-committed labor
participation.
I agree to be on call.
A hospital may call me.
I'm going to go to
work if I get the call.
But my salary is based
on whether I'm on call
all the time or not at all.
And I get to choose that.
Somehow that's the
flexibility in the contract.
And this is the decentralized
version with the household
optimization.
Firms maximize profits
and markets clear.
That's where we're going to
get the wage, the overall wage
and the interest rate.
So if you looked at the
first order condition
to the consumer problem, you
would see some obvious things
happening.
You're going to have a
theta price, shadow price,
on the budget constraint
that I just showed you.
And these probabilities
are entering symmetrically
in utility and in consumption.
So when you take
a derivative, they
are kind of like cancel out.
And so you get this.
But, look, here, they're
going to cancel on both sides.
So theta is common.
So consumption has to be common.
So you're going to get full
insurance on the consumption
side.
There's no reason to
let consumption vary.
Remember, this was a
separable utility function.
It was the utility
of consumption plus--
so why screw up the marginal
utility of consumption?
You can get full smoothing out
of on the consumption side.
So consumption is equal to each
other, whether you work or not.
But that theme may not
be at the boundary.
It could be interior.
So substituting a
common consumption,
remembering
disutility of work is
just m, you have this
new optimization problem.
And this is equivalent
with the other one.
Now, where's the
aggregate elasticity?
What's the disutility of work?
AUDIENCE: Phi, right?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: It's linear.
It doesn't get any more easy
to substitute than that.
See here it looks like
you're choosing phi.
But the coefficient in front
of it is just a number, m.
So phi is-- you know, why
is phi look like hours?
Phi is the fraction of
time you're working.
And if you work,
you're working 1.
So total hours is like the
fraction of the population
working.
That varies continuously-- this
sort of pseudo representative
consumer thinks that it can
choose any fraction it wants,
even though the underlying
population cannot.
This is a stand in household.
It's not a real household.
But the aggregates that
are predicted from this
will correspond to the
underlying problem.
So that was the insight
that Rogerson had.
And actually, I'm pretty
sure it's also 1 to 1
with the right welfare.
You can use that
aggregated utility
as a representation of
the underlying welfare.
Why is that?
Well, even though you
have all that diversity,
households are
really alike in terms
of their utility functions.
So expected utility
is the right metric.
And that's what that thing is.
It just looks funny
when you write it down.
OK.
And then quickly, here's
Hansen's version of it
with business cycles, going
to the actual aggregate data.
As I said, total
hours worked is hours
per person of
those participating
times the number participating.
And then you take
logs of it, basically.
And then you want to
look at a variance.
You say the variance of
a log of aggregate hours
has three components.
It's the variance of
individual hours, the variance
of participation on
the extensive margin
and this covariance term.
And in the US data,
those are the numbers
consistent with that table
that I showed you before.
So a lot of the
variability in hours,
say over a business
cycle or something,
has to do with
varying participation
among individual members.
OK, so this is sort of
familiar ingredients.
You'd have an
aggregate production
function over hours in capital.
You have some Markov
process on TFP.
You've seen this in the first
part of this class as well.
Capital depreciates.
You can add to it
with investment.
And you've got this
utility function.
Again, this is like a
Cobb-Douglas version, well,
logs off of a
Cobb-Douglas version.
And the overall
problem is to maximize
discounted expected utility.
Except we introduce
this indivisibility.
So you can either
work at h sub 0 hours
with some probability or 0.
Just like Rogerson with
slightly different notation,
you'd get alpha T, say the
probability of working or not
working.
You know, the way they've
normalized it, the log of 1
is 0.
This thing is going to drop out.
And you'll get a
utility function
over consumption and hours.
But remember, again,
just to reiterate,
h0 is the fixed number
of hours you have
to work if you work at all.
And alpha t is the fraction
of the population that's
being assigned to work word.
Alpha, this coefficient
in front of hours,
is the thing that's getting
determined in equilibrium.
So after you make all
those substitutions,
just like we did before
with Rogerson's paper,
we end up with
this pseudo utility
for the representative consumer.
And, yeah, again,
it's linear in hours.
So depending on the
wage relative to b,
it would look as if there's
just enormous willingness
to supply labor, or elasticity,
as you go from low wages
to high wages, you know,
an enormous response.
It's just a review
of what Rogerson did,
but it's in the context of
this business cycle model.
So solve the first
order conditions.
Compute the steady state.
Compute approximation
to the steady state.
Solve for the law of motion
of the endogenous variables.
And compute the moments.
Now, I don't want
to belabor this,
because it would just
take us too much time.
But we did models at
the beginning of class
that featured occupation choice
and development and so on.
This is like that
in the sense that we
have an attempt to match data.
In this case, in
this literature,
it happens to be
business cycle data.
But you're going to see Seema's
version of it in a moment.
So the cool thing is
you've got this machine.
You've got this model.
And if you're willing to take
a stand on parameters that you
observe in data or
calibrate other parameters,
you can generate time
series from the model.
And you can compare
the time series
to what you see in the data.
And this is the algorithm
for solving the model.
Again, I'm not going
to belabor this.
You know, they pick capital
share and depreciation rates
and discount rates and so on and
so forth and generate the data.
Now, they're two economies here.
This one with divisible
labor, this one
that we featured with
indivisible labor.
And you might want to look
at the variability of output
consumption and hours.
This is the variability
of ours in the data.
This is the variability of hours
without the indivisibility.
This is the variability
of hours with it.
Now, they didn't get it
all the way up to 1.66.
But they're certainly
dominating 0.70.
So that, you know,
as I keep saying,
these economies with certain
kinds of indivisibilities
are able to increase
the responsiveness
of aggregate hours to wages,
more consistent with what
we see.
Yeah, Matt.
AUDIENCE: Is this economy
with individual labor,
is it actually--
like one of your
student simulation--
is it identical to the RBC model
except the utility function?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah.
Well, except for the
indivisibility, yeah.
AUDIENCE: When you have
the utility function with
indivisibility, when you
have like the reduced form,
because don't--
I mean, in fact, again you've
got phi or the proportion
of time work--
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
That's what's going on.
See, there are two
economies here and kind
of two ways of doing business.
You could go to the micro
data, look at individual labor
supply, try to
populate the economy
with some fresh elasticity
that you observe in the data
and then go through
all the steps.
Or you could say,
no, no, no, no,
you either work
or you don't work,
get that pseudo household.
And it's going to generate
its own elasticity
and redo the simulations.
And that's what's
getting compared here.
Yep.
AUDIENCE: Compared to the
response of working hours
is totally driven by
the extensive margin.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yes.
AUDIENCE: If you
also want to match
the elasticity of this
extensive margin, maybe--
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yes, I'll
show you another paper where--
so this is too extreme.
But it shows how to get--
OK, so this is Kim.
I'll take you through
this really quickly.
But it does link up to the
incomplete market literature
that we talked about last time.
And the point is you
can generate a higher
aggregate elasticity than
what you see in the data
without assuming all this
stuff with complete markets
and the lotteries.
So in other words,
there's something
crucial about the aggregation,
which is more limited here.
We're not going to
get as high a number.
But we are going to get a higher
aggregate elasticity than what
you would think if
you just looked,
as Yeng was saying
really, if you just
looked at the micro data.
This is a nice paper--
I wasn't aware of it till
a few months ago actually--
because they're really
into the details
of the cross-sectional earnings
and wealth distribution.
They're really looking
at the micro data.
Whereas those macro
guys, at most,
are borrowing a few parameters.
You've got males and females,
like a two-member household,
maximizing expected
discounted utility.
This is again this Cobb-Douglass
type specification.
This is at the
aggregate household
level for some reason already
aggregated with these weights.
So it's male hours
and female hours.
Gamma is the sort of degree of
inter-temporal sub-elasticity
that we care so much about.
And now, they're going
to be serious micro guys,
and they're going to
actually look in the data,
at male and female wages
and impute productivity.
So these x things--
there's going to be one for
males and one for females--
take hours and multiply
by productivities.
And these productivities
can move around over time.
So it's not just a firm having
TFP that's moving around.
It's households having
labor productivity
that's moving around.
And the household
is going to have
this sort of standard incomplete
markets budget constraints.
So this looks a lot like what
we had last time sort of.
They're going to have assets
in the previous period
and interest on that.
They can save to take
into the following period.
And the household,
as a whole, is
going to have wage earnings
as a function of hours.
Now, we have labor supply.
We didn't have
that last Tuesday.
And there's, say,
a bound on assets.
This could be
zero, no borrowing.
It could be a negative
number, a limit on borrowing.
Just like the standard
incomplete markets lecture
from last time, we give them
an aggregate Cobb-Douglas
technology.
And we solve this
forward-looking value function.
So it's a bit bewildering.
But they're both working.
This e is not we.
It's like wee.
No, ee means employed
employed, employed not
employed, et cetera, depending
on the female and male members.
And this is the case
where currently they're
both employed.
Solving for assets,
you know, anticipating
that they'll decide on
their work status next time.
Now, again, you can see
this extensive margin here
is playing a big role,
deciding member by member
whether it will
be working or not.
And at least in the '50s,
this was a big issue,
increasing female labor
force participation.
Things have settled down now.
It's much more symmetric.
But the wife did not
always stay home.
Sometimes they
participated, depending
on the household situation.
So family labor supply, and
what do I want to say here?
So not much.
It looks more
complicated than it is.
You have this all for a steady
state, which is complicated.
Someone asked me-- who was it?
Can't remember-- about
adding state variables.
So here, you know, we have
a lot of state variables.
We've got male productivity.
We've got female productivity.
We have the
distribution of wealth.
All these things
have distributions
in the population.
And we have the sort of shock
in the aggregate production
function.
So they're going to do
what those macro guys do,
which is just look
in the steady state.
They have to compute it.
And then they're going
to look at very--
there's no time subscripts on
the wages and interest rates,
because you're in a
steady state, where
all this distribution
stuff has settled down.
You have a lot of
churning from one status
to another within
the steady state.
So individuals and
households are experiencing
different things over time.
But the economy wide
wages and interest rates
have settled down to constants.
And I'll skip-- they actually
start estimating parameters
with the micro data.
And, you know,
their goal here is
to get this aggregate
elasticity high,
higher than you
would see as they
estimate from the micro data.
So, Yeng, that's a
little better example
of actually looking at
the underlying micro data
and still using this sort
of macro aggregation.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: Still saying
that from micro data
the elasticity, so it's
made to be smaller.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Like even though
you have model, it just--
ROBERT TOWNSEND: That's right.
So why is it still happening?
Because, again, there's
this indivisibility
going on about whether
or not to work.
AUDIENCE: So if you incorporate
indivisibility, then--
because I thought
that point of Cheng
is that if you look at
the extensive margin,
that's still like
very small compared
to what the macro model
would be in individual labor.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah, again,
at the individual level,
you'll back out certain
low elasticities.
But the point of
this whole literature
is when you
aggregate up and look
at how aggregated hours
are moving around,
you can get bigger numbers.
It's not inconsistent.
Which brings me very briefly,
although fortunately, I've
said a few words about
this, Seema's paper
looks at productivity shots in
agriculture And, looks at what
happens to wages.
Now, you know, think
about a supply curve
and a varying demand curve.
So it rains a lot or
a little, that kind
of affects productivity.
That's moving the
demand for labor.
If the supply
curve is inelastic,
you're going to get a high
variability in the wage.
Her point is she cares.
The workers get hurt a lot
when there are droughts
and it doesn't rain
because the wage drops.
Landowners love it.
Their output is lower, but
they have less of a wage bill.
And then she couples that with
assumptions about how well
or how poorly the
banking system is.
So I'll just tell
you in words, she
has a 2-period problem, which
she thinks is enough, rightly,
to get what she wants.
She has people forward looking.
So they're solving
2-period problems.
And then you decide
whether or not to save
or to borrow based on
your current situation.
She's saying that if
they can borrow and save
in the banking system
is good, they're
going to be less needing to
work in a bad agricultural year,
because they can borrow
instead of working harder.
So this is an
incomplete markets model
with limitations and regional
variation in the banking system
that is focused on how
much wages move around
with productivity agricultural
productivity shocks.
Now, her paper is qualitative
in the sense that she shows that
there is with less what she
called wage elasticity--
there's less responsiveness
of wage to rainfall shocks
or instrumented
productivity shocks--
the better the
banking system is.
That's what she cares about.
Now, interestingly, she
doesn't get into the details
of the numbers.
How quantitatively big or
small is this response?
So she doesn't do
anything wrong.
It's actually a very nice paper.
But if she were seriously trying
to estimate the elasticities,
she would need to
take into account
whether there is this
extensive margin participation.
And the aggregate
level elasticities
could be lower than they might
seem to be as in the two papers
that we just covered.
So again, nothing wrong.
But, you know, when you're in
practice and development work
and you're thinking not just
about individual responses,
but sort of collective
responses and whole regions,
and so on then these sort
of tricks that we get,
lessons learned from
the macro literature
are very helpful in combining
the macro and micro data.
So you can read the
details of the slides.
But I basically covered it.
Thank you.